you gotta tell the story I don't even
know if Charlize knows about this but we
does get you in trouble occasionally we
didn't you finally like meet Steven
Spielberg who I guess is like you know
the guy to me yeah and and and you were
in them like smoking a joint in front of
him yes yeah what happens that I was
that yeah I was oh man and it's rich why
I mean not it's probably why I'm not
like in a lot of Steven my talent is
probably also that I was at a party yeah
and it was his party we should a big
party like I think it was that Jeffrey
Katzenberg night before party but he
plan would had to be so it's like a big
party with a lot of famous people at it
and I start I was outside and there was
someone else I knew and we started
smoking weed and I was smoking a joint
and like it was this awkward moment
we're like Steven Spielberg came up to
be like as I had this joint in my hand
and I could just tell like maybe he did
not like it like it was a very
judgemental moment and then you're
confronted with this thing where it's
like do I [ __ ] trying to hide I think
I just have to take ownership over this
and keep smoking this joint in front of
Steven Spielberg that is and I did yeah
and yes and I he always I've run into
him a few times and he always seems a
little disappointed so the whole time
you're talking to him yeah you said
that's it I gotta go I just gotta [ __ ]
smoke the [ __ ] I got it down this way
while the face-to-face with Steven
Spielberg